[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Montag an meiner
Seite ist für den Sport Norbert Lehmann
ein bitterer Tag ist das für die
Belegschaft von Deutschlands größter
Warenhauskette
Kahlschlag in den Innenstädten Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof schließt bundesweit
weitere 52 Filialen
treibt über krankenhausreform wie
Deutschlands Kliniken bezahlbar bleiben
sollen
Andreas
räumt das deutsche Kriegsdrama im Westen
nichts Neues gleich vier Oscars ab
[Musik]
Karstadt in Bremen steht zum Beispiel
auf der Liste Galeria in Leipzig zwei
von drei Filialen in Nürnberg insgesamt
52 seiner 129 Standorte will der
Warenhauskonzern Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof schließen weit über 5.000
Mitarbeiter werden ihre Jobs verlieren
schätzte Betriebsrat und spricht von
einem Raben schwarzen Tag Peter Böhmer
hat Details
am Mittag verrammelten sie im Dortmunder
Galeria Kaufhaus die Türen
Mitarbeiterversammlung dort dann die
schlechte Nachricht auch ihr Kaufhaus
wird geschlossen
Tränen bei manchen Mitarbeitern die von
der Entscheidung hart überrascht wurden
wir haben es noch gar nicht so ganz
verdaut also wir sind ziemlich mit den
Nerven durch das war mir auch schon vor
dem heutigen Tag sie sind schon am
Zahnfleisch gegangen und ist eine
Katastrophe von den noch 129 Standorten
sollen 77 erhalten bleiben 52 in zwei
Schritten geschlossen werden das
Unternehmen dass sich in erneuter
Insolvenz und im Schutzschirm Verfahren
befindet erklärte in einer
Pressemitteilung das ist zweifellos
heute für uns alle ein schwerer Tag wir
haben in den vergangenen Wochen intensiv
um jeden einzelnen entstandort gerungen
die verbleibenden Filialen haben eine
tragfähige wirtschaftliche Perspektive
Galeria hatte es trotz üppiger
Staatsgelder von 680 Millionen Euro in
den letzten Jahren nicht geschafft den
Schalter umzulegen die Mitarbeiterzahl
wird nur noch ein Drittel früherer Jahre
betragen
die traditionellen Kaufhäuser waren
einst Kunden Magneten jede Eröffnung in
den 50er und 60er Jahren ein
volksereignis
so möchten wir uns leiden und so möchte
die Jugend wohnen aber so will das
Publikum offenbar nicht mehr einkaufen
unter anderem die Konkurrenz im
Onlinehandel ist erdrückend und früher
aufgestanden
Kunden sagen das Kaufhaus oder Warenhaus
von heute ist Amazon wo wir in
Deutschland 500 Millionen Artikel finden
ein großes Warenhaus bietet vielleicht
200.000 Artikel an also das sind
mindestens 2000 mal mehr Artikel
deswegen hat sich das Thema erledigt
Ende März entscheiden die Gläubiger über
den Galeria insolvenzplanen stimmen sie
zu geht die Kaufhaus Geschichte
zumindest für die 77 Standorte weiter
welche Galeria Standorte betroffen sind
wann sie schließen und welche Filialen
bestehen bleiben das alles gibt's
gebündelt in der ZDF heute App
die Patienten spüren es längst viele
Kliniken in Deutschland arbeiten am
Anschlag mit viel zu wenig Personal und
viel zu hohen Kosten es muss sich was
ändern das ist allen klar die ersten
Pläne des Gesundheitsministers
allerdings sind umstritten heute gab es
dazu eine krankenhausgipfel dazu gleich
mehr zuerst zeigt Christoph das darüber
was die Regierung hat
das große Problem der Krankenhäuser da
sind sich fast alle einig sind die
Fallpauschalen denn Geld gibt es für die
Kliniken derzeit pro Eingriff je
anspruchsvoller desto lohnender deswegen
wird hierzulande besonders viel operiert
und deswegen will jedes Haus möglichst
alle Leistungen anbieten raus aus dieser
Sackgasse soll jetzt die klinikreform
führen sie will die Fallpauschalen
zurückfahren und die Krankenhäuser
wieder mehr fürs einfach da sein
entlohnen
und sie vor allem neu ordnen in drei
Gruppen die erste Krankenhäuser nur für
die ambulante Grundversorgung die zweite
wie ein Kliniken für etwas aufwendigere
Fälle Geburt oder Schlaganfall etwa und
Gruppe 3 Häuser die von Krebsbehandlung
bis Knie-OP alles können das soll Kosten
senken und effizienter machen und
gleichzeitig sicherstellen dass richtig
schwierige Eingriffe nur da vorgenommen
werden wo es auch maximales Know-how und
optimaler Ausstattung gibt oder aus
Patientensicht gesagt der Weg zur
passenden Klinik könnte bald länger die
Behandlung aber auch besser werden
ob die Behandlung tatsächlich besser
werden würde ist umstritten gerade im
ländlichen Raum ist die Sorge groß ob
Patienten wenn mehr zentralisiert wird
dann noch schnell genug in die richtige
Klinik kommen aus Bayern berichtet
Barbara Luke
Notaufnahme ein Mann ist nicht weit von
hier zusammengebrochen Herzinfarkt jede
Minute zählt es geht um Leben und Tod
deshalb ist es wichtig dass man
wirkliche schafft diese Leute vor Ort
schnellstmöglich in einer Klinik die die
Therapie auch machen kann unterzubringen
bisher ist das hier im niederbayerischen
Krankenhaus Rotthalmünster möglich doch
mit der Reform würde das Krankenhaus in
Gruppe 1 rutschen und nur noch Basis
Versorger sein Patienten wie der Mann in
der Notaufnahme müssten dann ins 40 km
entfernte größere Krankenhaus in Passau
den Rottal Münster würde etliche
Abteilungen verlieren die
Basisversorgung wird auf ein minimaß
heruntergedampft ich Vergleichs dann
gerne mit der Medizin jeder am Feld
Lazarett gemacht wird
große Kliniken hingegen als
Maximalversorger mit breiter Expertise
dafür wirkt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister heute noch
einmal auf dem Berliner
krankenhausgipfel
die Qualität der Krankenhäuser wird
durch eine Reform wie wir sie jetzt hier
planen besser weil wir tatsächlich dann
dazu übergehen würden die schwierigeren
Fälle und Behandlungen stärker zu
zentralisieren doch entfernen Rottal
Münster bangen sie nicht nur um die
Versorgung ihrer Bevölkerung sie
fürchten um ihre ganze Existenz denn als
reine Grundversorger Klinik in Gruppe 1
sehen Sie für sich und andere keine
Zukunft das bedeutet ganz einfach dass
jeder ca 60 bis 70% seines Patienten
Aufkommens des jetzigen Patienten
Aufkommens verlieren würde damit ist man
als Krankenhaus einfach nicht
überlebensfähig der Druck ist groß die
Finanzen Nöte der Kliniken gewaltig dass
eine Reform also dringend nötig ist
zumindest darin sind sich alle einig
mit seinen derzeit 736 Abgeordneten
gehört der Bundestag zu den größten
Parlamenten der Welt das liegt vor allem
am komplizierten Wahlrecht jetzt liegt
ein neuer verkleinerungsvorschlag auf
dem Tisch
regulär hat der Bundestag 598 Sitze doch
seit einer wahlrechtsänderung blähen
Überhang und Ausgleichsmandate das
Parlament immer stärker auf mit der
nächsten Bundestagswahl soll die Zahl
auf 630 begrenzt werden Patricia
für die Union ist es eine Attacke auf
die Demokratie die Linke sieht sich in
ihrer Existenz bedroht heftige Kritik an
den Plänen zur Wahlrechtsreform die
Opposition droht bereits mit dem Gang
nach Karlsruhe wir würden das CSU die
nicht zustimmen diese
veränderungswahlrechts wir werden wenn
sich nichts ändert auch eine Klage
dagegen einreichen one man one vote gilt
nicht mehr in Deutschland genau darum
geht es der Union mit ihrer Kritik vor
allem der CSU die immer besonders viele
Direktmandate geholt hat die Union will
lieber die Anzahl der Wahlkreise
verringern doch nach dem Plänen der
Ampel sollen nun Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate wegfallen wie jetzt
auch gibt es dann zwei Stimmen eine für
die Partei eine für den Direktkandidaten
gibt es dann mehr wahlkreissieger als
der Partei nach ihrem Stimmergebnis
zusteht kann es passieren dass ein
direkt gewählter Abgeordneter nicht ins
Parlament einzieht mehr als 630
Abgeordnete soll es künftig nicht geben
also wir verkleinern in den Bundestag
ganz erheblich um über 100 abge
getrocknete und deswegen können wir
nicht das System fortsetzen wo alle
Wahlkreis ersten dann auch tatsächlich
den Bundestag einziehen auch die
sogenannte
grundmandatsklausel soll gestrichen
werden diese galt für die Linke die drei
Direktmandate hat aber weniger als fünf
Prozent sie konnte trotzdem ins
Parlament einziehen künftig würde sie
leer ausgehen dass sie das jetzt machen
hat nur einen Grund nämlich politisch
die Linke mit ist das Wahlrechts platt
zu machen sein reines
Verhältniswahlrecht es geht um 5% der
Sitze die 5% der Stimmen die man braucht
um eben entsprechende Sitzverteilung zu
bekommen das ist für alle klar Ende der
Woche soll die Reform verabschiedet
werden wenn die Union wie angekündigt
klagt ist fraglich ob und wann sie in
Kraft hat
die Bundeswehr bekommt einen neuen
Generalinspektor nach übereinstimmenden
Berichten wird Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius Carsten Breuer mit dem Posten
des Rang höchsten Soldaten betrauen
Breuer ist derzeit Befehlshaber des
neuen territorialen führungskommandos
der Bundeswehr zuvor hatte er den
corona-krisenstab im Kanzleramt geleitet
Breuer folgt auf Eberhard Zorn
in die USA dort sorgt der Kollaps einer
Bank für Schockwellen an der Börse die
Silicon Valley Bank versorgte vor allem
Start-ups mit Geld ihr Zusammenbruch
weckt weltweit Erinnerungen an die
Pleite der Investmentbank Limon Brothers
2008 droht Ansteckungsgefahr eine neue
Finanzkrise experten verweisen auf neue
Sicherungsmaßnahmen doch alle schauen
gebannt nach Kalifornien Claudia Bates
verunsicherte Unternehmer die hier ihre
Konten haben kommen direkt zur Bank
wollen Klarheit
ich bin wie andere Gründer und
Vorstandsvorsitzende gekommen um
herauszufinden was eigentlich passiert
ist und was unsere Optionen sind wir
müssen ja sicherstellen dass wir unsere
Angestellten unsere Kunden und
Investoren schützen
die Aktie der Bank war stark unter Druck
geraten eine geplante Kapitalerhöhung
scheiterte andere Banken gerieten mit in
den Strudel die New Yorker signature
Bank wurde am Wochenende geschlossen
inzwischen steht die Silicon Valley Bank
und der staatlicher Kontrolle die
US-Regierung versucht zu beruhigen will
eine Bankenkrise abwenden
die Amerikaner können darauf vertrauen
dass das Bankensystem sicher ist ihre
Einlagen sind da wenn Sie sie brauchen
die Silicon Valley Bank hatte hohe
Summen in langlaufende US-Staatsanleihen
angelegt deren Kurse sind durch die
Zinserhöhungen der Notenbanken deutlich
gesunken so geriet die Bank in die Krise
der Kollaps schürt nun Sorgen vor
weiteren Zusammenbrüchen
fragen wir Frank Bethmann an der Börse
in Frankfurt droht auch deutschen Banken
eine Schieflage Commerzbank und Deutsche
Bank haben heute erst einmal
beschwichtigt so ließ die Deutsche Bank
mitteilen und sei nicht bei der Silicon
Valley Bank engagiert beruhigt aber hat
es die Börse erst einmal nicht im
Gegenteil die Aktie der Deutschen Bank
bereits am Freitag mit Abschlägen
verliert weiter fast 5%, die Commerzbank
gar über 12%. die relevante Frage dürfte
dann tatsächlich auch sein haben
heimische Banken ähnliche Probleme mit
den Leitzinserhöhungen wie ist die
Silicon Valley Bank hatte denn wie das
Geld aus dem Kalifornien halten viele
Banken Staatsanleihen und teilweise
haben die jetzt eben stark an Wert
verloren wenn Finanzinstitute diese
aktuell verkaufen müssen sie Verlust
hinnehmen geraten unter Umständen in
eine gefährliche Schieflage eine solche
Gefahr sieht der Bundesverband deutscher
Banken für heimische Geldinstitute
allerdings so gut wie nicht die
heimischen Banken sein robust auch
Süddeutsche Bankenaufsicht beruhigte die
Finanzstabilität in Deutschland sei
nicht bedroht die BaFin handelte zudem
sie schloss die deutsche Zweigstelle der
Silicon Valley Bank hier in Frankfurt
Dankeschön für diese Informationen aus
Frankfurt frank bedmann war das
die Tarifeinigung bei der Post steht
seit Samstag doch in anderen Branchen
wird weiter um mehr Lohn gestritten und
gestreikt heute traf es wieder Fluggäste
in Hamburg und am Hauptstadt Flughafen
BER wurden alle Staats gestrichen auch
in Hannover und Bremen hatte die
Gewerkschaft Verdi aufgerufen die Arbeit
niederzulegen Hintergrund sind parallel
laufende tarifkonflikte vor allem im
öffentlichen Dienst
China zu neuer Stärke bringen das ist
das erklärte Ziel von Staatspräsidenten
in seiner dritten Amtszeit gerade
wiedergewählt hat er jetzt konkreter
gesagt was das heißt die Wirtschaft muss
wachsen um rund 5 Prozent und viel mehr
Geld als zuvor soll ins Militär fließen
Miriam Steiner berichtet aus Peking
die Tagung von Chinas scheinparlament
ist eine Show jeder Zentimeter jeder
rechte Winkel nichts passiert hier
zufällig und alles wird auf sein
Kommando der neue alte Präsidentin Ping
nutzt diese Bühne um zu demonstrieren
dass er auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Macht
angekommen ist in seiner beispiellosen
dritten Amtszeit will er seinen Traum
verwirklichen China soll Nummer eins der
Welt sein mit Hilfe des Militärs
wir müssen die Modernisierung der
nationalen Verteidigung und das Militärs
umfassend vorantreiben und die
Volksarmee zu einer großen stahlmauer
ausbauen die die nationale Souveränität
Sicherheit und entwicklungsinteressen
wirksam schützt
er hat die Regeln abgeschafft die als
Lehren aus der Alleinherrschaft von
Staatsgründer mau zu Dong und dem Chaos
das er verursachte eingeführt wurden
in den Führungsgremien gibt es keine
konkurrierenden Fraktionen mehr ebenso
wenig wie ein regelmäßigen Machtwechsel
statt eines führungskollektivs bündelt
er alle Macht in seiner Hand
er hat sich hier seine Macht von Chinas
scheinparlament noch mal absegnen lassen
und dafür gesorgt dass ich daran dass er
der Vorsitzende von allem ist in
absehbarer Zeit nichts ändert
was er jetzt braucht wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung da die Begrenzung abgeschafft
ist könnte dann auch eine vierte fünfte
oder gar sechste Amtszeit folgen
so sehen Sieger aus das ist das Team von
im Westen nichts Neues auf großer
hollywoodbühne noch nie war ein
deutscher Film bei den Oscars so
erfolgreich mit insgesamt vier Trophäen
besser internationaler Film beste Musik
beste Kamera beste set design von der
großen Freude und dem historischen Abend
berichten
[Applaus]
ein deutscher Film gewinnt 4 Academy
Awards war neun Mal nominiert das gab es
noch nie im Westen nichts Neues schreibt
Oskar Geschichte das ist einfach
historisch es ist unvergesslich das hat
es noch nicht gegeben Regisseur Edvard
Berger bedankte sich vor allem bei
Hauptdarsteller Felix Kamera
es war dein allererster Film und du hast
uns alle auf deine Schultern getragen
ohne dich wären wir heute nicht hier
Danke Felix
im Westen nichts Neues ist ein
erschütterndesdrama erzählt aus der
Perspektive eines jungen Deutschen
Rekruten im Ersten Weltkrieg
eindrücklich gespielt von Felix Kamera
der Film ist brutal realistisch zeigt
die Verzweiflung die Angst der Soldaten
[Musik]
und das sinnlose sterben in den
Schützengräben den Oscar für den besten
Film des Jahres und sechs weitere Preise
bekommt everything everywhere all at
once der Abräumer des Abends erzählt die
Geschichte einer depressiven
waschsalon-besitzerin auf wilder Jagd
durch parallele Universen ausgezeichnet
für die besten Nebenrollen Jamie Lee
Curtis und King Michelle jo gewinnt als
erster asiatischstämmige Schauspielerin
einen Oscar für die beste Hauptrolle
Ladies lasst euch von niemanden je sagen
ihr hättet das beste hinter euch
die Filme dieser Nacht waren nicht die
Milliarden Kassenknüller sondern die
Dramen unserer Zeit das Ringen um
geistige Gesundheit den everything
everywhere all at once und der Kampf um
die nackte Existenz und für ein Ende
jedes kriegswagens ein historischer
oscar-abend
freuen wir uns mit jetzt zu den
deutschen Skispringerinnen nach
Lillehammer da hat zwar nicht für den
Sieg gereicht aber immerhin für Platz
zwei starke Leistung von Selina Freitag
gestern hatte sie noch beim Springen von
der Großschanze das Podium knapp
verpasst heute musste sie sich nur der
Norwegian obset geschlagen geben bei
widrigsten Wetterbedingungen
starker Schneefall machte das Springen
der Frauen in Lillehammer bei der
zweiten Station der Tour in Norwegen zu
einer echten Herausforderung
Weltmeisterin Katharina Althaus nach dem
ersten Durchgang nur neunte mit ihrem
starken zweiten Sprung landet sie am
Ende immerhin auf Frank 5 Berliner
Freitag trotzdem widrigen Bedingungen
mit
121,5 und 128 Metern springt sie auf
Platz zwei und landet damit nur 0,6
Punkte hinter der Norwegerin
sechs Wochen nach dem WM Triumph haben
die Deutschen hockey-männer im
pro-li-wettbewerb wieder eine Niederlage
einstecken müssen und das erneut gegen
Gastgeber Indien der
rekord-olympiasiegergewand klar mit
sechs zu drei
20.000 indische Hockey Fans begeistert
zu desorientiert bisweilen die weiß
gepressten Weltmeister aus Deutschland
so zielstrebig und entschlossen die
Rekord Olympiasieger Indien spielt
Deutschland mit unterschwindlich liegt
zur Pause mit viel zu zwei Formen
lobenswert wie gewohnt aber der
unbändige Kampfgeist der deutschen die
durch malte Hellwig noch mal auf 3:44
herankommen Indien im schlossviertel
jedoch mit den größeren Kraftreserven
habe ich hängt mit dem Sex zu drei gegen
müde Weltmeister die in der Tabelle auf
Rang 4 bleiben
Erfolg für Skipper Boris Herrmann und
seine Crew bei der Weltumsegelung the
Ocean Race denn auf der ersten Hälfte
der schwersten Etappe von Südafrika nach
Brasilien schafften sie mit ihrem Schiff
maurizia vor Tasmanien den zweiten Platz
in der Zwischenwertung und liegen jetzt
insgesamt auf Rang 35 Boote sind jetzt
noch im Rennen
und 7500 seeme sind geschafft noch so
rund 5000 Seemann bis zum Ziel Genua
danke schön
heute war es ungewöhnlich warm für Mitte
März das wird aber nicht so bleiben
Details zum Wetter hat gleich Katja
hornerfahrt um 9:45 Uhr begrüßt Sie
Marietta Slomka im heute-journal wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend eben noch Winter jetzt schon
fast Sommer das war ein richtiger Ritt
durch die Jahreszeiten heute mit
kräftigen Gewittern im Westen und dem
Südwesten Deutschlands in Rheinfelden
stiegen die Temperaturen bis 24 Grad
aber so mild bleibt es nicht denn diese
warmluftblase wird schon morgen nach
Osten abwandern das Tief Florin bringt
deutlich tiefere Temperatur mit in der
ersten Nachthälfte haben wir es noch mit
weiteren Gewitter und vor allen Dingen
in Baden-Württemberg zu tun sonst fällt
häufig Regen bei einem starken
bestimmten Südwestwind die Temperaturen
sinken auf 10 bis 3 Grad und klettern
morgen auf 7 Grad in Ostfriesland bis zu
14 Grad im Spreewald morgen Vormittag
sind die Regenwolken der Nacht in
Südosten ab dann wird es zwischen
Thüringen und der Uckermark freundlich
von Westen kommt schon die nächste
kaltfrontan die bringt erstmal Regen mit
im Laufe des Tages sieht er aber weiter
Richtung Südosten dann gibt's auch
wieder Gewitter und Schnee Regenschauer
es gibt auch wieder Orkanböen es wird
also sehr windig und der Wind dreht von
Südwest auf Nordwest weitere Regen und
schneeregenschauer gibt es am Mittwoch
der Donnerstag wird schon ruhiger und
der Freitag mit guten Abend